Next question today.
Hey David, should underage girls have to have
their rapists babies?
Listen, this is very, very simple for me.
The answer is no.
Okay.
Is the mother better off having a baby that
they didn't want to have, particularly when
they are under age girls?
The answer is obviously not.
Is the baby better off having such a young
parent that they didn't want to have them
to begin with?
The answer is obviously no, and there are
more and more states as we've been talking
about for the last couple of months in this
new era of a very conservative Supreme Court,
thanks to Mitch Mcconnell's, obstruction of
Merritt garland during the Obama Presidency,
Donald Trump defeating Hillary Clinton in
2016 and then appointing two people to the
Supreme Court in this new era of Supreme Court
conservatism.
There are a lot of anti-choice activists that
are now starting to put proposals out that
say you do have to have the baby.
If you are a victim of rape, you do have to
have your rapists baby.
I'm against this.
But it's important to understand that a lot
of this is strategy from the right.
Two weeks ago, I believe it was, uh, when
we talked about the Georgia and Alabama bills,
I pointed out to you that, um, I believe a
lot of conservatives agree that rape victims,
particularly under age girls shouldn't be
forced to have their rapists babies, but they
are playing the longer game and they are playing
the game really well, which is they want to
get one of these laws contested, uh, blocked
by an immediate lower level court appealed
all the way to the Supreme Court of the United
States, hopefully to get a supreme court ruling
that will contradict Roe v Wade and allow
an easier path to state level bans on abortion.
So, even though there are definitely some
anti choice people who genuinely, sincerely
believe that underage girls should be forced
to carry to term, uh, the babies of their
rapists, I think a lot of, uh, anti choice
people are just saying it because they understand
the sort of strategic goal of getting one
of these cases to the supreme court in order
to further the anti choice movement over the
long term.
Now I also want to point out the reality is
that in practice these laws banning abortion
even in cases of rape, um, will cause more
babies to be born to poor mothers and to mothers
who are not equipped to be mothers.
Because wealthy people are going to be able
to continue getting abortion safely, right?
Private clinics that operate discreetly, the
ability to travel to nearby states that haven't
banned abortion, those are things that are,
are much more accessible for middle class,
upper middle class and rich people.
So what you perpetuate by doing something
like banning a exceptions for rape and incest,
for example.
Uh, when it comes to abortion, what you perpetuate
his mother's having children who are likely
to be poor, which the right claims is bad
for society.
Uh, why are they pushing a policy that would
actually perpetuate more of that?
It's all because of this broader strategy
of trying to get something to the Supreme
Court, getting a favorable decision that is
antiabortion and then using that to justify
all sorts of state level abortion bans and
they're carrying it out really damn well.
Uh, and we should all be activating against
it and we should all be making sure that Donald
Trump doesn't get another supreme court pick
who, which would be truly an absolutely disastrous.